controlling how you live and control
your own destiny and take life by its
throat what's that believe nation this
channel is designed to be a part of your
daily success routine and help you
believe in your Michael Jordan level
talent so today let's learn one of the
most common rules that successful people
follow take control of your life also if
you want to learn what Mel Robbins Gary
Vaynerchuk
Terry Crews and others have to say about
building unstoppable confidence check
out my 250 for confidence series where
every day for the next 254 days I will
send you a morning video for free to
help you build your confidence the link
is in the description below when you
have an intention on something that you
want to change about your life your
brain helps you the reason people don't
put themselves in a position to fail the
reason people aren't patient is they
value other people's opinions too much
whatever you thinking about it you will
not get it until you take action
[Music]
recognize what really makes you happy if
you feel like you lose and you losing it
doesn't matter what other people feel so
I know how it feels to be perceived as
winning and be feeling like I'm losing I
stopped living according to what people
wanted me to do I started living
according to what actually made me happy
but if you in a situation that don't
make no sense then get out of it don't
make it make sense
one plus one always equals two if you've
not happy change your life you know I'm
always looking for new ways to explain
the power of the five-second rule and
the power of five-second decisions and I
read something that Tim Ferriss said
that really resonated with me and he had
this one line buried in a podcast
somewhere that just jumped out and it's
it's it's stuck and what he said is he
said something about how there's a gap
between the world and the things that
trigger you and your response and your
entire life is that gap when you start
to this is not what he said he I kind of
identified this gap and I of course
intrinsically was like well absolutely
that's the five-second window between
instinct or stimulus and your reaction
and when you start to understand that
your whole life plays out in this
five-second gap and that there's a gap
that's five seconds long between fear
and courage and there's a gap that's
five seconds long between self-doubt and
confidence that is your life and what's
super cool about understanding that your
whole life is inside this gap is it's so
small everybody that you have the
ability to control it life's always
going to throw triggers at you and there
will always be all kinds of cool things
that inspire you your wisdom and you get
to choose what happens in that gap do
you succumb to an excuse or do you push
yourself forward when you start to speak
up in business you'll be shocked at how
you start to speak up and your
relationships when you start to make
hard phone calls whether it's in a
selling situation you'll be surprised at
how you'll start to close the gap and
have hard conversations in your personal
life and so that gap is everywhere and
it's the same every
and when you start to go to work in
controlling how you live in that gap
between stimulus or idea and your
response that's where the magic is
I was working once in an ice-cream
parlor when I was about 15 years old my
first real job and on the second day I
was asked to scrape the gum off between
the Mexican tiles on the floor and I
said to the woman who owned the storms
called Magoo's ice cream parlor you
didn't hire me to scrape gum you hired
me to scoop ice cream and this this girl
my shoe store across the way that's
looking at me I don't want to see her
you're scraping the gum and she said
what you're talking about
I own this store I'll do anything I want
with you get down on your knees and
scrape that gum but I said I'm not doing
it she said you're fired last job I ever
had I owe that woman everything I don't
like to work for people many of you
would hear I hope and inherit that
there's nothing wrong with it if you
want to control your own destiny
you'll work for yourself that's how it
works I'm trying to inspire those of you
who are on the tipping point take the
chance you're young go for it
there's nothing better than being able
to wake up in the morning 10 years or 20
years so now and do what ever you like
it's about freedom that's what matters
I'm not saying being an employee's bad
but believe me being an entrepreneur is
better I'm a little biased just enough
enough enough
like living by somebody else's rules is
a humongous mistake I just literally sat
down with five people under the age of
27 and it's so refreshing it is so
refreshing if you have not jumped on the
bandwagon of doing exactly what the you
want to do which is skiing for the next
three years or working at a job that's
not what your parents want or what
society wants this video is just called
enough enough make this little 1 2
minute video depends on when I finish
the piece of content that gets you to
stand up and take life by its throat do
something stopping scared stop letting
the way you were raised the fear as an
offense take that away let me be the
person I'll take the blame
I loved that some of my plays are like
my parents don't love what you're saying
good parents because if you are playing
defense and if you are living a life
where your kids lives are the way you're
being fulfilled you're a loser
parents and so enough enough parents
imposing their way you want your kids to
be happy on your terms enough the kid
that's sitting right now in a desk and
saw this in a feed and you hate your job
I'm not stand up get the [ __ ] out of
here and do you live your life you've
got one life do something about it
there was a moment in my career actually
right before I started my lingerie line
and I had an old agent telling me you're
not a cover girl you are only gonna be
my money catalog girl and you're just
gonna be under the radar I waited on him
to build a career for me and I waited on
him to kind of guide me into success and
the moment that I let him just kind of
step to the side line and I took control
over my own career is the moment that I
started to skyrocket and I could have
had it earlier I really believe happy to
think people think happiness is all
about money happiness is never ever
about money happiness is about being
able to control your own life that's all
you want uh-huh it don't matter what you
got in your bank but if you can control
your own life you happy that's the
beauty and that's what everybody's
mixed-up yeah because you got all this
money but if somebody else is
controlling you so Shakespeare said
there's nothing either good or bad but
thinking makes it so
and I think it's true nothing is
actually inherently good or bad it's
your attitude it's your approach it's
how you interpret it but then changes
the course of your life there are some
people who walk around and they can find
a way to be negative about everything
you know some of these people they are
just always negative something is always
wrong there's always drama that that
circulates them that follows them that
they didn't want to inflict on other
people but just really
happy people constantly and these others
who are positive were optimistic always
seem to be happy always seem to be
smiling and those are the people that
you want to be around why like they
might have the same light there they
might work in the same building and yet
one is negative one is positive
they're just interpreting things
differently the positive one chooses see
the good and negative ones choose to see
the bad and everything that happens and
so people asked me how am I always
positive and optimistic and upbeat and
is this an act like this is Who I am
what I will how I share on this channel
here this is me this is who I am I don't
go after pressing stop and then hate my
life like I'm a positive upbeat guy I
just choose to see the good in things I
think this is an amazing world I think
no matter what's happening in the world
that that we will win that I'm on board
with Team humanity like it's gonna be
great we will solve these problems this
is the best time ever to live and and
even that line of it's the best is
something that came up recently at my
workshop in Toronto at this workshop
helping people make money from their
ideas it was three day event and one of
the things that came up over and over
and over again is it's the best like
anytime we had a little problem that
happened my dog peed on the floor one
time this fire alarm went off is like
it's the best this is awesome take the
fire alarm for example you know I just
split people up into three different
groups they were in three different
locations fire alarm goes off it's easy
to get agitated by it I'm trying to
learn here I'm trying to understand this
message why is this fire alarm going off
I can't concentrate I can't think I'm
not learning I can't focus rah ha ha and
you freaked out the fire alarm is going
off anyway freaking out gate and angry
is not gonna solve anything right so
what I did was I walked around to each
of the three groups and said guys is the
best like being able to learn through
this situation it's the best now it's
not that you welcome problems and you
want problems that calm you you want all
this negativity in your life you don't
welcome it you don't want it to come
you're not saying hey problems please
come find me but when they come what's
your reaction to it problems are coming
for you they come for everybody do you
see this big overwhelming thing that you
get frustrated and angry I want to
complain about or is it the best and you
make the best of it and you find your
way through now that's easy when it's a
fire alarm or when the dog pees on the
floor when you're stuck at a trap
light or an elevator and you get
frustrated and you want to turn that
into it's the best great what do you do
when it's actually a major problem what
do you do if it's somebody in your
family dies or has cancer or there's
abuse or drug use or all of the negative
stuff that happens in our lives
how do you turn that into a positive
before you throw tomatoes at me let me
let me try to shift the perspective and
say that it's the best I'm a big
believer that your purpose comes from
your pain if you look at the people that
have done the most the most good for the
world it comes from a deep source of
pain my passion to help entrepreneurs
comes from my feeling unworthy as an
entrepreneur when I first got started
and how low I felt of myself having no
self-esteem self-confidence because I
worked because I wasn't making any money
and I just felt worthless as a human
being and I don't want other people to
have to go through that we like that
people came to my workshop and their
purpose their mission what they are so
excited for that the big change you're
trying to make in the world is coming
from their own struggles growing up from
massive points of pain and the pain that
they went through some of them is is you
know you wouldn't wish that on your
biggest enemy but because they went
through it because they survived it
because they dealt with it
they developed coping mechanisms for it
now they want to make sure that that one
that never happens to anybody else ever
again and to that the people who it does
happen to they want to help them not
have to feel the same pain they want to
help them know that they're not alone
they want to give them different coping
mechanisms to deal with it and so yes
even in these really negative deep dark
extremely painful places if you can
learn to say this is the best to still
feel the pain to know that this sucks
but to know that getting through it
makes you stronger gives you purpose I'm
gonna allow you to help other people if
you can find in your heart to say this
is the best
that's when your life really starts to
change and so nothing is either good or
bad but thinking makes itself hi guys
I'm Carly class and welcome to my
youtube channel you clearly run your
brand over a billion users for YouTube
so you look at those numbers and say
this is smart business it did I had an
opportunity to do something with a
channel with Network that was ultimately
going to be in the hands of producers
and editors in a dark room somewhere but
I didn't have control of it and and I
had that realization and I realized I
want to control my story you've got a
production company with your husband and
friends now yes obviously with the me to
movement and with so much of that going
on in Hollywood at the moment to see a
woman producing her own film and
starting her own production company and
sort of operating stuff from behind the
scenes as well as being on camera is
really really lovely for the rest of us
I'm good I'm close I'm part of the
decision its holder was it just
something it was I mean the point of the
company was to promote women in films
whether that be the female protagonists
know with female lead content or through
female storytellers I think if we want
to see an change in this industry we
have to have more women in positions of
power and that's when things will really
change and you'll get a lot more
authentic version of a female story
sometimes not always though Craig told
the story we were brilliantly and I've
worked with quite a few directors male
directors who tell female stories
wonderfully because they don't see it as
a male female story they see them as
people but no it was definitely the
driving force behind our company to
promote women in film and to also a
chance for me to kind of control my fate
a little more and take matters into your
own hands a little bit what was your
life like before you became the Iceman
and actually I was a father of four kids
and bringing them up alone because my
wife accidentally the 95 so that kind of
like adversity and and sadness
maybe motivated you to oh yeah inspire
yourself and in the same way a lot of
people
yes a deep trigger where I got peace was
in these breathing exercises swimming
outside in the cold the coldest
merciless but righteous as well all the
people say you know that you cannot
steer a life or you cannot do this and
yeah it's part of life and it's destiny
and it is fate fate and their destiny
and all that no this time we learn to
control our happiness health and
strength and that's not philosophical or
sectarian it's chemistry now I've got a
really special bonus clip from Tom bill
you around how to be in control of your
life that I think you're gonna really
enjoy but before that it's time for the
three point landing questions time to
move from just watching under the video
to actually taking action in your life
or your business so here we go question
number one what do you need to take
control of in your life or business
number two whose advice in this video
resonated the most with you and why and
number three what are you gonna do about
it this week
and as Bruce Lee said if you always put
limits on everything you do physical or
anything else it will spread into your
work and into your life there are no
limits there are only plateaus and you
must not stay there
you must go beyond them even in the
statement you can see him making the
choice about what to believe by saying
that there are no limits by taking
something that other people perceive as
a limit is something that's stopping him
and saying that's not it's a plateau
it's something that I can push through
and you see what he holds himself
accountable to it's not okay to stay at
a plateau it's okay to have one
everybody has them they happen it's a
natural part of the course of getting
better but it is not okay to stay there
and that is a choice that's not
something anyone can hand you it's
something you have to believe to the
core of your soul that it is not okay to
stay in a plateau and it's the back
that's gonna push you through it's that
that's gonna make you get up and keep
going
but first
you have to recognize that life is
cause-and-effect you have to recognize
that that choice is a knock-on effect
you have to recognize that him merely
saying those words out loud have a cause
and effect
they changed the course of his life the
expectations that other people have of
him expectations that he has of himself
and because he understands that he can
control the outside world by first
controlling what's inside by changing
his belief system to match what he wants
to accomplish he's then able to
accomplish what he did in his life have
nothing to do with luck it had
everything to do with the demands that
he made on himself it had to do with
winning he got in a motorcycle accident
people told him he would never walk
again not only did he walk again all of
the major accomplishments that we think
about him being that man they all came
after they came after he was told he was
never gonna walk again after he was told
that he was never going to be able to do
martial arts but he did it he did the
grueling work of getting better he
understood cause and effect he
understood that if he chose to believe
that he could never do it that he'd
never be able to do it but that if he
chose to believe that by working out he
could get stronger and get better and
get back to it that he could and that's
what he did
so now ask yourself is your life
dictated by luck or cause and effect
are you in control or is it somebody
else is someone else in control or is it
you and if it's you go build the life
that you want because there's nothing
stopping you but you raise your standard
Apple at the core its core value is that
that people need passion and not one
drop of myself work depends on your it's
something serene if you guys want to
learn the 10 skills that are hard to
learn but will pay off for life check
out the video next to me I think you're
gonna enjoy it continue to believe and
I'll see you there
one of the things you would want to be
sure to do is whether you like it or not